[Music]
alright guys let's be honest at this
point csgo is an old game it's 8 years
old and while it's been getting a lot of
love lately occasionally it can show its
age throughout its history csgo has had
plenty of weird bugs and rng you know
the type that make you with a shot that
you know you should have hit or the type
that just kill you in a situation that
you should have survived in held it even
happens to the pros with that in mind we
decided to count down the top 10 x pros
got over by the game itself starting us
off is a moment that makes us question
what the hell is really going on with
knives and csgo it's a double-edged
knife right there yeah playing against
hellraisers during ESL pro league season
10 na'vi had secured the round pretty
handedly and everything was going
according to plan
that is until flamey knifed and killed
simple now would love to see that simple
was running away and they turned around
and flaming his knife the air and killed
him you know I've done that before
look we've all knife to tea main spawn
by accident it happens but that's not
what happened here
flamie and simple or nowhere near each
other i guess csgo works in mysterious
ways coming into the number nine spot is
one of the weirdest whiffs you'll ever
see fnatic were in their prime in 2015
but you wouldn't know it looking at this
play although let's be honest this time
it probably wasn't their fault at ESL
pro league season 2 the Swedes were up
against envyus
and the game was unfortunately basically
over but pronax had a chance to steal
back the round and keep fnatic alive too
bad csgo itself came in and said and it
is not gonna be enough who next two
heads just staring him down it's not
gonna be it's not gonna be that exciting
in the end is it's gonna be envy then
who pick it up in beautiful fashion at
number eight on our list we have a bug
that nearly destroyed a major in 2017
big was able to make it to the legend
stage of a major for the first time ever
unfortunately for them it was partially
off the back of a newly discovered bug
on inferno only you just a few pistols
to start off with where he can see but
he can't be feat the jump ugh as some
people called it allowed players to see
over certain walls and obstacles without
alerting their enemies which gave any
team using it a huge advantage in
certain situations
unfortunately pgl determined using the
bug was legal and no team caught more
heat for abusing it than big make any
sound there as well notice this silences
jumps sorry that they don't even know
he's there jumping getting free
information no risk and as a free fire
eventually all 16 teams at the major
came together and made a gentlemen's
agreement not to use the bug for the
rest of the tournament but for one brief
moment it really seemed like the jump
bug could have torn that major apart at
number 7 is a moment when our and Jesus
stood between a young Stewie 2k and a
head shot in an ESL pro league match
against optic gaming cloud 9 were ready
to pounce on to the a site on cash and
Stewie had a perfect shot lined up on
the unsuspecting DAPs
and then inexplicably he missed getting
everyone a position oh no there's that
first bullet accuracy
you've got to love it luckily the rest
of c9 cleaned up the kill that orangy
stole from Stu why want me to replay
that guys why is why is your cell trying
to just tilt me here dream it can
trigger Moses it's unreal people often
complain about how wonky CS goes
hitboxes are but our number six entry
should remind you that it used to be a
lot worse at fragbite masters fnatic
we're trying to retake a site from nerd
rage on Mirage now with his team's
comfortable lead olofmeister decided to
ball out and try to stop the defuse
before it happened he climbed on to
ticket to stop the planter and lined up
his shot only to completely whiff trying
to find a way over here pronax has
managed to spot it how is that not a
kill he looks dead on there sure his
scope was a little blurry but everyone
knows that when someone's planting the
bomb hitboxes get weird anyways this
moment left similar and the rest of us
at a total loss for words coming in at
the halfway point on our list is a
moment where csgo just decided to give
up altogether oh there's no way there is
no way in a match between envious
Academy and Amiga gaming at the hell
case Cup Namita
were in a 2v2 situation and ready to
execute onto the a site until they
realized the bomb was nowhere to be
found
it literally fell through the map there
is no way that has happened valve for
God's sake oh I'm so done there's no no
way
taking the number-4 spot is probably the
scariest moment the Molotov smoke bug
ever produced now in case you guys
weren't aware the molle bug caused
smokes to fail at putting out Molotov
and before valve patched it out of the
game he terrorized csgo Oh
CS goes and its finest yep but we're
pretty sure this particular moment is
the worst example of this bug to ever
happen in a pro game you're looking at
SK versus Team Liquid at ESL one New
York 2017 in double overtime I might add
with a bug nearly killed fallen leaving
him with just two health and the smoke
nearly costs him as he goes down to two
HP we lose this smoke is 8 big tummies
valve at the number 3 spot on our list
is a moment where everything went wrong
for all ooh the Train even dress the
wall back dream he still I saw huh in a
losing bid against non-us fencer at Star
Series season 7 hence were down 1510 on
overpass now feeling that they could get
a cheeky pick on to heaven they set up a
gigantic boost so that all who could
take out an unsuspecting CT
unfortunately for him are in Jesus put a
train in his way so and suede it out but
even after that csgo intervened yet a
game this one just hurts to watch make
it this time
and he's got all the train all the train
even tries to Wallbangers dream he's
still a soul huh
I'm sorry what texture does that hit you
he might be shot as well when the train
came past because obviously the crowd
cheered he's thought all no they know
I'm here I'm gonna just take a potshot
if I can gets an opportunity go for the
second that doesn't laugh taking the
runner-up spot on our list is the time
Kerrigan suffered a cruel fate at the
hands of a bad deagle now the deagle can
be a challenging weapon to wield but the
pros can make it look easy a dreamhack
open tours 2019 mousesports was down 73
against valiance and Kerrigan kind of
shot at making a comeback in a 1v3
situation as he stared into the soul of
his unsuspecting opponent the Dave fired
and missed you just hate to see it I
don't know how else to sum that up other
than a feels bad man did he just get
mega CS code though I looked on that's
the crazy I was my first reaction it's
not hit him in the head taking the top
spot on our list is CS Gogh's greatest
tragedy the tale of Rob's and how he
suffered the wrath of a vengeful chicken
see chickens RC s goes ever-present pest
and most players just sort of deal with
them but there are a few times when the
chickens fight back
cs:go has blessed our feathered friends
with just enough AI to occasionally
completely [ __ ] us over
and unfortunately for ROPS he became the
victim of the chickens wrath at Star
Series AI league season four drops has
to hold on to his chick in blocking the
door I've not seen that before that gets
him killed oh my god
a chicken bak in the door just got Rob's
killed love to see it you know it's very
rare it happens
let Rob's punishment serve as a lesson
never mess with the chickens alright
guys that about does it for our list
today and I've only got one question
left for you if you haven't subscribed
to the channel yet what are you waiting
for we're trying to get to 2 million by
the end of the year and we can only do
that with your help so hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
and let's go alright so obviously we're
all working from home now quarantine you
know trying to keep everybody safe but
it means that I'm working with a less
than optimal PC at least when it comes
to gaming see we're gonna have like csgo
in houses in the office and I obviously
want to participate in those even
disadvantaged as I am with my current
hardware so I spent the weekend
optimizing my toaster so it could play
csgo it's 2020 and I am 800 by 600 I am
every setting on very low I've got all
the launch options you can possibly
think of and it does barely run although
god forbid if I have to run through a
smoke or a Molly or something it just
drops frames like crazy